- [Baji] Hello everyone!
Welcome to DAT410.
This is PostgreSQL Performance:
Real-World Workload Tuning.
Let me ask you this.
Have you ever received alarms
at 3:00 AM in the morning
due to degrade of database performance?
It could be high CCP utilization
or high query execution times
or plans are switching, then yeah.
We are going to see,
today we're going to see
a few common performance challenges,
which most of us face and fix together.
My name is Baji Shaik
and I'm a senior database engineer for RDS
and Aurora PostgreSQL databases
and I have a co-speaker.
- [Vlad] Hi everyone, I'm Vlad Vlasceanu.
I'm the tech leader for
databases here at AWS.
I'm here to help Baji, so
if you have any questions,
please raise your hands
and I'll come with the mic to you
so you can ask the questions
so everybody can hear it
and then we'll try to
answer your questions
to the best of our knowledge.
- [Baji] Sure, thanks Vlad.
So let's start with it.
Before starting the content,
I just want to start a load generator.
I have a slide to talk
about this load generator,
just started the load generator.
So yeah, meet Mr. John.
He's a senior database
engineer at any company.
He's responsible for PostgreSQL
databases in his company.
He did pretty good job in installing,
setting up PostgreSQL databases.
He tuned it very well
and it set up all monitoring all alarms,
but eventually data grows.
He started seeing alarms
at 3:00 AM in the morning
due to query execution times are high
and CPU utilization is also high.
Does that sound familiar?
Then let's fix PostgreSQL
performance issues
of John together.
Before that, let's look
at the key areas to focus
for performance tuning.
I would start with CPU utilization.
It could be due to sub-optimal
queries, which are going to
full table scans, which
is high CPU intensive.
And your application workload
is undersized for the instance
where you see high CPU utilization
and by default PostgreSQL
uses parallel queries.
So if you have large
number of parallel queries,
you'll see more number
of connections using CPU.
So that's where you see
high CPU utilization.
Next thing to look at is memory.
Again, sub-optimal queries,
memory intensive queries.
And then PostgreSQL uses
process based architecture.
So each connection is a process
which consumes some memory.
So if you have high number of connections,
you'll see high memory utilization.
And PostgreSQL has some
memory related parameter
based on which you control the memory.
But if those parameters
are over configured,
that's where you see
high memory utilization.
Next thing to look at is storage and IOPS.
So PostgreSQL uses multi-version
concurrency control mechanism.
So every modification to the database
will have two versions
of rows, old and new.
The old version of row called as bloat,
which will be cleaned up
by maintenance activities like vacuum.
Otherwise you'll see high
storage and IOPS utilization.
And if you have more indexes
which are unused or duplicate,
every modification to the database
will lead to update those
indexes unnecessarily,
which is where you see
storage and IOPS utilization.
And PostgreSQL uses work memory
to control the query
operations such as sorting,
but if that memory is insufficient,
that's where it create
temporary files on disc,
which is high IOPS activity.
And next is application pattern.
So if you have large number of queries
which are blocking each other,
that's where you see slowed
database performance,
not due to query executions,
but those queries are
conflicting each other.
But if you have long
rendering transaction,
our idle-in-transaction
for longer period of time,
which will block the maintenance
so that eventually
database will slow down.
So if you have more number
of ideal connections
which are doing nothing,
they still consume resources,
which is where a connection pooler
would help to optimize the connections.
So these are a few key areas to focus.
Next, we can look at
query tuning methodology,
which is a step by step process
where you would start with
looking at active session summary
in database insights,
performance insights,
or you can look at pg_stat_activity
view inside the database
and you can look at top SQLs
and top wait events
consuming those resources.
And you will generate explain analyze plan
with buffers option where you can see
shared buffers information as well
and investigate from that.
So it's a step by step
and iterate to process.
So you need to find out the top SQLs
and start fixing from there.
But how does an explain
analyze plan looks like?
So this is a simple plan.
So every arrow mark
represents the plan node
and the top row is the
consolidation of all the plan nodes.
So it has, if you observe
first row and every plan node,
there are two sections to it.
So first part is estimations
and second part is actual.
So let's look at the number.
So first number is estimated startup cost
and then total estimated cost,
and then total estimated
rows and then you know,
width of each, average width of the row.
And the next section is actual
where it starts with actual
startup time in milliseconds.
And this is total, next is
total time in milliseconds
and the total number of rows
for that particular query.
Every plan node has these two sections.
So if you look at the second
part of each plan node,
so that's execution time of
that particular plan node
and the consolidation is the top row.
So the top row has the
number of rows executed
with that particular query.
And next is the loops, number of loops.
If you have complex query,
you'll see more number of loops.
So that's the kind of basic
for explain analyze plan,
but what problems to look
at in explain analyze plan.
So in the demo we have
several problems to look at in detail,
but at high level, it'll
start with bad estimates.
So if planner is dependent on statistics,
if the statistics are not up to date,
you'll see bad plans and
execution times are high.
And you can look at sequential
scans, full table scans
which are CPU intensive
where an index can help.
But if index is already there
and a strategic index can help
to improve the performance and
you can look at buffer reads
with buffer's option in
explain analyze plan.
And as I said, you need
to look at each plan node
and pick up the slow operation
in that plan node and start
investigation from there.
This is a e-commerce...
We have a simple e-commerce app,
that's the load generator
I have started with.
This app has simple
e-commerce tables like orders,
products, users,
and we have the load generator
that's what I started.
So it opens the connection to the database
more than 150 connections
and it has balanced reads and writes
and it provides summary every 30 minutes
on how many queries run,
we can see that in demo.
These are the five
critical performance issues
we're going to cover.
So we will cover in detail
in demo, but at high level.
First one is how rewriting
a query could help.
And second one is, it's
going for a different plan,
but other plan can help,
how do you switch between the plans?
And third one is you
already have an index.
How can a strategic index can help
to improve the performance?
And fourth one is heap
only to pull updates,
how can that help to
improve the performance?
And we have some lightweight
logs we can see in the demo.
And what are those logs and
how can we fix those logs?
This is the content. We
can start with the demo.
I will just switch back to demo.
Is this okay, it's visible or
you want one size to increase?
All okay?
So this is the load
generator I've started.
It has eight queries that are running
and it gives you information about
how many times each query run
and aggregation of the queries
for that particular 30 second interval.
As we fix the queries,
we can see improvement
in these number of queries.
And switching back to the
console, this is the instance.
You can go to performance insights
of that instance.
Let's select last 10 minutes
and you can see different wait events
where CPU being the most top wait event.
You can see more than 60, 70
sessions are consuming CPU,
but we have a lot of wait events.
I'll go to Database Insights,
which is an extended version
of performance insights
and continue monitoring from there.
And if you select last maybe 10 minutes,
you'll see the same wait
events where CPU being the most
and I'm switching back to terminal
and let's connect to database.
And I was talking about
pg-stat-activity view as well
congest a query pg-stat-activity view
of substring(query, 1,20)
from pg-stat-activity view
where that name is,
database name is e-commerce.
So you can see all connections
to the database more than 150 connections.
So this all are running
against database and if you see
all our inserts, selects,
updates, all sort of queries.
So it has balanced read
and writes to the database.
So let's go back to the console
and select the CPU wait event,
which has peaked the most.
If I scroll down, you'll
see the top queries
that are consuming the CPU.
So today we are going to fix
top five queries one by one.
Another thing to monitor is
if you go to database telemetry section,
you have individual
metrics on CPU, memory, I/O
and all sort of monitoring.
If you view metrics in CloudWatch,
you can create your own dashboards
to monitor these metrics.
I have a simple dashboard created
with metrics like CPU,
read IOPS, write IOPS,
all those basic metrics,
we have commit latency
and all those.
And if you see the CPU,
the last 15 minutes,
which is touching 100%.
So now let's go back to database insights
and pick up those top
queries and fix one by one.
I'll just select last 10 minutes
and then the CPU wait event.
If you scroll down, you can see the query.
So this is a select function call
which is consuming more CPU resources.
If I check that query,
this is the query that's
running against database.
So let's see the DDL deal
of this query, this function
and see what's inside it.
So it has only a single select query
with a predicate to a function call.
So if you execute this function,
sale movement type is coming to this query
and the overall function
gets the count of all sale movement type.
But if you execute, explain
analyze on this query,
it's gonna take time.
So a few minutes back
I have executed explain
analyze on this function
just to save some time, it
takes more than one minute.
So if you explain analyze
buffers for that function call,
you don't see much information
on explain analyze directly
on the function.
For this you can use plprofiler extension
which gives you the internal
query details of the function
or you can check the
function and manually execute
the explain analyze for
the queries inside it.
So as we have only one query,
I just did explain analyze on that query.
So we are gonna spend a couple of minutes
to deeply look at this
explain analyze plan
and then for other queries
we can just spend less time.
So this is the explained analyze plan,
the arrow mark that I talked about.
This is the plan node, one plan node
as we have only one query,
one table, one query single,
it's a strike query, that's
why we have one plan node.
And this top line is the
aggregation of all the plan nodes.
So now first thing to do
is which plan node is slow?
So I have only one plan node.
If I look at the plan node,
the cost, estimated cost is over 3 million
and rows are nearly 2 million.
And actual time, total
time is around 60 seconds.
And the rows returned by
this plan node is 1 million,
only 1 million.
So now another couple
of things to look at is
rows removed by filter
are 10 million rows.
But if you observe this plan node
is returning only 1 million
rows, but planner thinks
10 million rows should be
removed from what it has done.
This is because if you
look at the number of rows
in the same table, the 11 million rows
and if you group the
movement type for sale,
this is 1 million.
So this sale movement type
is what it's returning here.
So, and if you exclude that
sale, that's 10 million rows,
which is where it's removed by the filter.
So now what's happening is for each row,
this function call gets executed.
That's why it gets executed
for all 11 million rows.
And then planner realizes that
sale movement type is only 1 million row.
So I need to remove all
the row that I've worked on
for 10 million rows, it should be removed.
So if you observe this is
unnecessary work for planner
to go to 11 million rows
to execute that function.
And if you look at shared
hit, these are in blocks.
So 87,008 KB blocks are
fetched from the memory.
So that's high if you
multiply 87 by 8K bits
around 800 megabytes or something.
So that much data has been read.
Now if you look at this plan node,
it's going for sequential scan,
which is a full table scan.
But if I look at this table DDL
with \d option, you can see,
well I'll connect back once again
and then look at the DDL for this table.
This is the moment type index.
So there is an index on
movement type column,
but it goes to a sequential
scan for this query.
This is because planner
doesn't know the value
that's coming from this.
If you execute this
function with a select call,
then it gives you sale.
But planner doesn't know
what value it's coming there.
So that's why for each row
it's executing that function.
So to make the optimizer aware
of that sale movement type,
if I change the query to maybe,
I'll take this query from here
and explain analyze buffers
and if I use select
call for that function,
if I go back to the function name,
so if I add a select call to that function
and see what happens, it
should pick up that index
because it knows that sale
comes to that filter column.
So first time it's gonna
take time because if you see
it's going for index scan,
that's what we wanted.
So now select call gives index hint that
you should go for index scan.
And if you observe I/O timings,
this is for the first time,
index has to be loaded into memory.
That's where you see I/O timings there.
But if I run it again, as
it's already in memory,
it took 10 seconds earlier and
now it took 800 milliseconds,
but initially it was nearly one minute.
So we brought down the
execution time from one minute
to 800 millisecond.
Not only that, you don't
see that rows removed
by filter here.
So planner exactly goes to the
sale movement type rows here
and if you see the shared buffer hits,
it was 87,000 8 KB blocks.
Now it's just 2000 8 KB blocks,
which is very, very less work for planner.
That's why execution time is low.
But if you look at all of the metrics,
the cost was 3 million,
earlier it's 43,000
so everything came down.
So to fix this query, we just
need to rewrite this query
to use the select call.
I'll just do that.
I'm just modifying that function
to use that select call.
And now if you see the
definition DDL of that function,
you can see that select
call has been added.
So every connection that
comes after this modification
should go to index scan if I
go back to my load generator.
So function calls for every 30 seconds
are only just nine queries.
If you keep monitoring,
if you wait for next
summary to be displayed,
then you can see the improvement
in that function calls as well.
So now it improved to 12 queries.
If you wait for a few minutes,
you'll see the improvement,
actual improvement.
Another thing I'm
switching back to console
to look at other stats.
If I go to a dashboard,
if I scroll down to,
maybe I'll pick up commit
latency, even cloud watch metrics,
if I select for last 15 minutes.
So it's slowly coming
down, it was around 23
and now it's coming to 21.
So commit latency for function
calls has been reduced
and it gives more resources
to other queries as well.
So you can see little
improvement of number of queries
for other queries as well
because resources are consumed
by this function call are less now.
So, and we can see other
metrics like queries finished,
maybe I'll go for this metric.
If you go to CloudWatch
and deselect all metrics
and select only queries finished,
so this should also get
improved over the time.
So you can see it's improving
the number of queries.
If you see the total query
time, this should get reduced.
So it started with 5
million and now it's at 525
because other queries are also running.
It created resources for other queries
but it eventually comes down.
So that's how we can rewrite the queries
to improve the performance.
This is an example to rewrite the query.
So if you're using function
calls to our predicate,
make sure you use select call.
Otherwise, optimizer will get confused
and it takes a sequential full table scan
instead of index scans.
If I go back to database insights-
- [Speaker] I think we have a question.
- [Baji] Oh, so.
- [Speaker] Is there any
reason you would want to,
like why would we not always do this?
Or is this just like, why
would you ever not prefix it
with a select to call a function directly?
Does that make sense?
- [Baji] If I understand
the question,
so why would we need to
add that select to call?
- [Speaker] Why would
you ever not do that?
Like I didn't even know this was a thing
and like I'm thinking about
all the queries I've written
and like man I should be
doing this everywhere.
Is there any reason we
wouldn't wanna do this?
- [Vlad] Yeah, just to
paraphrase, he's asking
why the database engine would
not automatically do that.
(indistinct) talking line it like a-
- [Baji] Yeah, understood.
Yes. Yeah. Thanks Vlad.
So why database engine
itself picks up that
as a select call.
That's the question, right?
Yeah, it's a kind of, so,
but yeah, that's how optimizer works.
It only looks at the function call.
If it doesn't have, it
has to execute that call
and get the value for that filter type.
But if you have that select call,
it already execute that call first
because it's a subquery now,
it's not the actual
filter, it's a subquery.
So it executes the subquery first
and then gives the value
to the further rows.
Thank you.
And if we observe the next queries,
I'll fix this third query first.
Any questions?
- [Speaker] Yeah, yeah, sorry,
I had a few questions on this example too
just before you get too much into this.
Did earlier when you were
running those explain plans,
did you,
I thought the first time you ran it,
you said that you weren't
getting very much,
very many details.
Did you run a second one
before you made that,
tested that fix?
- [Baji] Oh, this is
because of the I/O timings.
I mean the first time it has
to load the index into memory.
So all the extra lines are related to I/O
and he fetches is I/O timing line.
So that's where it's-
- [Speaker] Did you
have to add a parameter
or something that they explain
to have it come out with more details
or is this just the regular explain?
- It's just the regular,
it is just (indistinct)
- [Speaker] Oh okay.
That was the difference.
Okay, thank you that
was what I was asking.
That's what I wanted to know. Thanks.
And then one other thing,
all of these like Postgres,
like command line things you're doing
such as the explain plan
or like the \d function,
are those something that you could
or would want to do in the AWS console?
- [Baji] Not in the AWS console
but any client tool like PG
admin or other client tools.
You can use those client tools
to see the details of the tables
and what indexes, what
functions, everything,
can be done through client tools.
- [Speaker] Just one more,
just a very quick follow up.
Is there a significant difference between
what things you shown here
and if you're doing Aurora PostgreSQL?
- [Baji] Oh, this is Aurora PostgreSQL.
- [Speaker] Okay, thank you.
- [Baji] I'm so sorry. I
haven't mentioned that.
If you go back to the console,
this is my Aurora instance
that I started looking at.
- [Speaker] So the explain
as a standard (indistinct)
that you use it for any
Postgres flavored database?
- [Baji] Yeah, yeah,
there is nothing special
if it's RDS Aurora or community Postgres.
So next query that I wanna
pick is the third one.
If you look at the query,
it's getting average price
for the products for certain category,
only for the active products.
If I select this query and generate
and explain analyze plan, perfect.
This goes to index scan,
a bitmap index scan.
The difference between normal index scan
and bitmap index scan is for
index scan, it takes one row
and get fetched from the index file.
So for one row, one iteration
but bitmap index scan,
it takes a group of rows
and it goes to fetch all the rows at one.
So it reduces the number of
iterations to the index files.
So that's why bitmap
index is more efficient
than normal index in some cases.
So perfect, it's going
for bitmap index scan,
it's going for index scan.
But the two things that we
looked at the last query,
we are again looking at here.
So you can see 30,000 rows
were removed by this filter
and 13,000 8 KB blocks are fetched.
So if I look at the query,
it's getting average price
for the certain category
which is active.
Only for the active products,
it's getting the information.
But if I look at only
active inactive products
from the products table,
it's only 33% of the products are active.
So if I know that I always
select the active products
and not the inactive products,
then I can clearly create a partial index
on the same category column
with only for active products.
Let's try to create that index.
I'm using concurrently option because
all the queries are running in parallel.
So IDX for category and only
active on products table
on category column, where
is_active = to true.
So this is the partial
index I want to create.
So let's create this index
and execute the explain plan
and see the difference.
So now it goes for bitmap
index scan for that new index
and if you observe these two metrics
and rows removed filter are only 900 now
where there were 30,000
and the execution time is 360 milliseconds
and 23 milliseconds now.
And buffers are only
10,000, there were 13,000.
So some less work to do.
So now as we have created the index,
I'll just go back to the load generator
and if you observe the
function calls were 9, 12
before we fixed the first query.
And now eventually you can see 489 queries
are running for that function calls.
So it's a lot of improvement
due to that index scan
for the first query.
Now let's look at strategic index.
It's the number of
queries are 1200, 1,200.
And now after creating that
index you can see 1200 to 2000,
almost 100% improvement.
So aggregation of the queries are 20,000
now after we fixed the couple of queries,
but initially when we
started, it was 15,000.
So we have 5,000 more queries
running for the same
workload, same instance.
I haven't changed anything
at instance level,
just fixing the queries,
improved 15,000 to 20,000.
So now let's go back here and
go to the next query to fix.
- [Speaker] A question.
- [Baji] Sure.
(indistinct)
- [Speaker] Would that not have helped,
instead of using like active, right,
and you have a multi column index.
- [Baji] Okay, if I
understand the question,
so why can't we have a composite index
on category and is_active?
- [Speaker] Because we can't be creating
like these so many indexes for
different strategies, right?
- [Baji] That's right but again,
if you create a composite index,
is_active has inactive products as well.
So we want to filter only
active products specifically
because I know that I always
search for active products.
So if you go for composite index,
it still have large number
of rows removed by filter
because that category have
any number of inactive products as well.
So a composite index might
not be the right choice here,
a partial index would work well.
So that's why we created specifically
on the active products.
Any other questions?
- [Speaker] Oh hi, couple
of questions, right?
So first one, we are taught for long that
the index scanning happens
from the leftmost column on the predicate.
Right now, we are picking
something in the middle.
Is that something we are
supposed to benchmark
before we roll out?
- [Baji] Oh, this happens because
of the data grows as well.
So let's say you only have active products
for 90% of the products stable initially
and your A category
column index works well.
But now eventually data grows,
some of your products
become active and inactive.
Now inactive amount has 66% of the table.
So that's where you see, but
if you benchmark initially,
it would've gotten best performance.
- [Speaker] Got it, got it.
So the other question,
building on top of the question
the gentleman raised over there,
the more indexes we
create, I mean, so that
essentially indicates that we
need to periodically monitor,
observe and optimize.
I think that's probably the whole plan
because otherwise what happens is
you end up creating indexes on
every single one of those columns, right?
So if you plan it ahead of
time, which you cannot, so.
- [Baji] No, I understand. Yeah, yeah.
So the more indexes, you'll get
less performance for
modifications to the table, right?
So yeah, yeah.
If you are creating that partial index,
you can keep observing the
first index of category
and that is not being used
other than this index.
You'll keep monitoring the index scans
for that particular table,
that particular index.
And if you observe that that
index is not being used,
you can get rid of that index.
We have how to get those
annual indexes as well
moving forward. but yeah,
that's a good question.
So yeah, we can create
index on single columns.
- [Speaker] Right. Thank you.
- [Baji] Thanks.
- [Speaker] Hey, maybe I missed it.
When you, that last example,
what was the indication that
there was something wrong
with that, with that query
and then how did you know
that an index would fix that?
- [Baji] Oh because I looked
at the inactive products,
active products inside the table.
So I know that only 30%
of my table is active.
- [Speaker] What was the
initial like red flag
that this was?
- [Baji] Oh this, this, this two.
So rows removed by filter are high.
So actually planner worked
on inactive products as well
and then it realizes and
removed all those inactive rows.
- [Speaker] So you want
a low number of rows
removed by filter because
it's doing more work like-
- [Baji] That's-
- [Speaker] Every time.
- [Baji] Correct. That's
a hint there. Yeah.
- [Speaker] Oh thank you.
- [Baji] Thank you.
So let's go to this query.
If I select this query,
if you observe this query,
I'm not sure if it's visible,
I'll just paste it here with
the next plan, analyze plan,
buffers, and then query.
And this goes to index scan.
So let's observe the
query so it has a hint.
Like we use in Oracle,
this can be done through the
extension called pg_hint_plan.
I already created pg_hint_plan
and at initial days of my application
I provided hint to go
to this particular index
because that index
performs well for my query.
So now as I hinted for
this particular index,
now you can see index scan
using that particular index.
So all good.
But again, the red flags same,
rows removed by filter are 400,000
and the buffers fetched
are 400,000 8 KB blocks.
But why, why optimizer
went to that bad index
because you hinted?
If you observe the predicates,
you have created_at in total amount
and this is where a
composite index can help.
So, but if you look at
the detail of the table,
orders_table, I already
have that composite index.
So if you see this index
alert, already have that index,
but it still goes to
the single column index
and created it column
because I hinted for that.
The simple solution is
to just remove that hint.
So optimizer is smart enough
to pick the right index,
so let's remove the hint
and see what happens.
So it should pick up that composite index.
Create so it went to
createdat_amount composite index
and if you look at rows removed,
there is no rows removed by filter.
So it exactly knows how
many rows to locate.
And shared buffer it's are
only 37,000 from 400,000,
so which is a significant reduce.
But yeah, now we know the solution.
Simple solution is to remove
that hint and it works well,
but it needs an application change.
That query will be at different places
and removing that hint is
not short term solution.
Maybe you can plan for a long
term solution to remove it,
but as a short term solution,
how do you make this query
to use the different index
without changing the query?
So this is where
query plan management
extension from Aurora helps.
So using this extension you
can capture the right plan
and switch the plans between the queries.
So this can be done using
apg_plan_management extension.
So if I create this extension,
it'll give you DBA plans table
where it capture all the
plans that hit the database.
So if I create this plan
and if I run this query,
I will just drop the
extension and recreate it.
- [Speaker] Yeah, I
have a question for you
about the extensions.
So right now the Aurora
product team has not guaranteed
that extensions will
be forward compatible.
So is that gonna change on the roadmap?
So for example, if we begin
to rely on this extension
and then as the product moves forward
and it's no longer supported,
it could put us in a little
bit of a difficult situation.
So are you guys endorsing that
or how are you helping
work with the product team
to make sure that
any extension that we pick
will be forward compatible?
- [Baji] I'm sorry, Vlad, do
you want to take that question?
I just want to restart my instance once.
- [Vlad] Yeah, I mean
honestly we are working
with the service team to make sure
that some of these capabilities exist
and they become forward compatible,
but we're not yet at a point
where we can just guarantee it yet.
So I think you generally
can't expect that.
It's just we can't make that
as a guarantee just yet.
In time, I think, you know, as
more of these extensions get,
let's say a level of maturity
that we're comfortable with,
we would be able to make
that type of a guarantee
but right now we're not quite there yet.
But still it's a tool, it's a release,
it's supported right now by AWS.
So if you need to use it by
all means go ahead and do that.
- [Baji] I had to reboot the instance
just because I created extension
and I dropped sometime back.
So that needs a restart of the database.
So I just restarted it. Go ahead.
- [Speaker] Is this
only available in Aurora
or RDS also, this extension?
- [Baji] This is specifically for Aurora.
- [Speaker] Okay.
- [Baji] Yeah.
So now if you look at DBA plans table,
it captured plans for all
the queries that are running.
So all inserts updates select everything.
So if I only specifically query for
our query that we are working
on, which is created_at.
- [Speaker] It's rebooting
(indistinct) that's common?
- [Baji] Yeah, yeah if you
create and drop extension,
it needs a reboot.
Yes, this plan has been captured here,
but just for no visibility,
clear visibility, I have a query
that just use JSON
function to bring the index
that is being used for
that particular query.
So it just, it's on DBA plans,
but it's a simple query.
If I execute this query, you can see that
this query's plan has
been approved in status
and this is the plan hash
and this is the SQL hash.
So plan for this query
is already captured.
That goes to create an index.
Now let's remove that
hint and run the query
to capture the plan again.
So now if you run this query,
in the note it says an
approved plan was taken
because that has, but
instead of minimum cost plan.
So this query plan has
been captured already,
but Aurora knows that
there is an approved plan
I should go for that.
So it still went to created_at
index plan, the old plan,
but it captured the new plan.
So what I need to do is to
look at this DBA plan's table
and there is another plan which goes to
created_at amount table,
the composite index.
Go to composite index and
this is unapproved at.
So if I unapprove this,
reject this and approve this,
it should go to the new plan.
So that's how we can
switch back the plans.
Before that we have Aurora
stat plans function,
which will show you plans being
used for the live queries.
So if you are running queries
and you are confused which plan is taking,
you can use Aurora stat plan function
to see which plan exactly that's taking.
So I'm just going for my queries tab,
and this is a simple query
on Aurora stats plan function
with filtering that particular query.
If I execute this,
so index can hint query,
this goes for orders
created_at single column index still
because I haven't approved the new plan.
If you look at the number of calls, 1800.
If I run the same query
again, it is 2000 now.
This is because these
queries are coming in
and it's taking the old plan still.
So that's why you see number
of calls being increased
for this particular plan.
So now, how do you switch these plans?
So, other plan management
comes with a function
called set_plan_status.
So using the set_plan_status function,
you can reject or approve particular plan.
It just need SQL hash
and plan hash as inputs.
So already built two
statements on this function
with SQL hash of new and old plans.
If I just execute to approve the new plan,
sorry to switch back between the windows,
but if I approve and reject
plans, and if I go back to this
now the plan with composite index
created_at an amount is approved now
and old plan is rejected.
Now the assumption is it
should take the new plan
with composite index.
How do you check that?
So again, you can execute
Aurora start plans view
for that particular query.
And now if you see there are two rows,
this is for old index created_at,
there are 2,493 calls.
With the new index composite index,
there are 1,200 calls now if I run again.
So this is constant
because it's not taking that old plan now.
This will keep increasing.
So now we fix that query.
If we go back here,
the plan instability
queries are around 255, 260.
So now the plans stability
queries are 800, from 255 to 800
and total number of
queries increased to 24,000
and previously they were
16,000 and around 20,008,
20,000 with two queries fixed.
And now the queries count
increased by 94,000.
So we looked at how to rewrite
the queries the first one.
Second is we have the index,
but we can create a strategic
index, partial index
to improve the performance.
Third is you have the right
index already created,
but how do you switch
back between the plans
to use right index?
Next thing to look at is
if I go back to Cloud Watch metrics,
the update query is
consuming more resources.
So if you look at this update query,
update products set on nodes column.
So if I look at the TDL
of this products table
and indexes that table,
there is no index on
nodes column if you see.
So now, Postgres has a feature
called heap only triples.
If you are updating a non-indexed columns
within a data block, if there
is some space inside it,
then instead of updating the index,
because this is a
non-indexed column updating,
so instead of updating the indexes,
it'll just create pointers
inside that data block.
So it doesn't need to update the indexes.
So that iteration of that
work has been reduced.
So this is called as heap only couples,
but you need empty space
inside the data block.
So this is defined by
fill factor in PostgreSQL.
So if you look at the fill
factor for this table,
this is 100%.
So I'm saying right to the entire block,
don't leave any space.
So that's the meaning of fill factor 100%.
Now hard to pull needs some space
either those are created by
vacuum for the empty spaces
or you specifically need
that percentage of need free.
Yeah.
- [Speaker] Yeah, sorry,
I have a quick question.
So is a query plan is gonna
be the same for the writer
and reader instance in the same cluster?
If it's not the same,
like where do you see
it's gonna be different
to be optimized for each of them?
- [Baji] Sorry, did you
understand the question Vlad?
- [Vlad] So what you're
showing there on the screen
with the query plan, the question is,
if you have a cluster of multiple readers
or writers and readers,
do you need to make that change only once
or do you have to make that change
on every one of those instances?
- [Baji] Oh, it has to make the change
on the writer instance so
reader instance will be updated.
- [Vlad] So it's propagating
from the writer instance-
- [Baji] Writer instance.
- [Vlad] To make that change there
or propagate to to the plan changes.
- [Speaker] Is there cases
that they have difference
because the writer and reader instance,
that's gonna be used for
more read-only workload?
- [Baji] Are there cases
when you know they have to
you need to have them being different
between readers and writers?
- [Baji] I am not aware of any cases.
- [Vlad] Yeah, I'm not sure either, yeah.
I haven't seen any but...
- [Baji] If it's the same query
then it has to be same index
because that gives you better performance.
- [Vlad] Yeah, I mean
the results of a query
are gonna be deterministic
no matter where you're running it,
subject obviously your replication lack.
- [Baji] But if there is
a slight change in query,
then SQL hash will change and then,
that will not work for the query, yeah.
- [Vlad] Yeah.
- [Speaker] Yeah. Sorry, quick question.
So what you mentioned is
what about query changes
optimizations we do
on the writer instance,
it's automatically propagated
to the reader instance, right?
But it's not bi-directional, right?
So, what I optimize on
reader instance will not,
because oftentimes we run into
reader instances, you know
that a lot of reads going to
the downstream systems like
(indistinct) whatnot, right?
So the reader instance is always
resource intense in nature.
So we end up optimizing a
lot on the reader instance.
- [Baji] What kind of
optimization on specifically
for reader instances?
- [Speaker] What about query plans, right?
So similar stuff we did
on right instance, right?
But it's not,
those queries basically
hitting the reader instance.
- [Baji] Yeah, that's same question-
- [Speaker] It's not bi-directional
in nature, right? So?
- [Baji] But if you want a different plan
on the reader instance?
- [Speaker] Right?
- [Baji] Yeah, it's the same question.
So yeah, so it has to be,
if it's the same query, it
has to be same plan, right?
At least I'm not aware of the cases,
for the same query, I
need two different plans.
One will work on writer and
one will work on reader.
At least, I'm not aware
of those cases. Yeah.
- [Speaker] Alright, thank you.
- [Vlad] I mean structurally
the data is physically laid out
in storage the same
way, it's same storage.
So there's no reason you
would have the same query
needing different
performance optimizations
on different instances.
The question is that you
might only run that query
on the reader instances because
it's feeding downstream systems
and it doesn't run on the writer
that it's not gonna impact
the performance of the writer.
But the optimization is
still valuable intrinsically
because it's, again the
query is deterministic
in its response.
It's always going to
produce the same response
given the same input data.
- [Baji] Okay, coming
back to the HOT updates.
So I need fill factor to be reduced
to maintain some free space in each block
for those index pointers.
So that can be done by
changing the fill factor
for that particular table,
using this command set fill factor to 80%.
Now I changed fill factor, but
that's not immediate effect
because my all blocks are filled now.
I need to reorganize the blocks
to leave that empty space for every block.
That can be done by vacuum full.
Vacuum full is acquires
access exclusive log
so I need to get rid of the connections
to improve the vacuum full time.
So I'll just kill the connection
and load generator is
smart enough to restart
when you kill the query.
So, pg terminate backend
using pg_stat_activity
where database name is e-commerce
and pid not in the pid that
I'm currently working on.
If that pid gets killed,
then you cannot move
forward with the session.
So I'll execute vacuum full
analyze on products table.
It's gonna take few seconds
to execute that vacuum full,
maybe five or six seconds.
So after that vacuum full,
now you will have space
for 20% space for those HOT updates.
If I go back to the load generator,
let's check if it's changed.
In the table DDL, now fill factor is 80%.
You can check whether updates
are going for HOT or not
using pg_stat_user tables.
There is a column in pg_stat_user tables,
n_tuple_hot_update.
So this column shows how many HOT updates
for that particular table.
Let's get the percentage,
I'm just going to my query,
this is HOT updates.
So I'm selecting how many
updates, how many HOT updates,
and the percentage for
that particular table.
If I execute this simple select here,
then there are 70% tuples
going to HOT updates.
If you keep observing, then
you'll see performance,
the ratio will get increased.
So 72, 72.1 and it'll keep increasing.
So now there are more
HOT updates to the table.
If you go back to load generator
and HOT updates are here,
they're 2,300, previously
also they were 3,800,
but we restarted the instance
so it takes time to pick up.
So you will eventually see
the more number of
queries for HOT updates.
So that's where HOT updates help.
If you have updates on non-indexed column,
it can create some free
space on each data block
to have those pointer instead
of updating the indexes.
Now, you can see 3,900,
almost 4,000 queries.
Previously, they were around two to 3000
so a lot of improvement.
If I go back to this
and the fifth query we
have is this function call.
If I select this and this
and this is my function.
- [Speaker] There's a question.
- [Baji] Oh!
- [Speaker] So we
originally started by saying
that there's no index on that column.
So it was going to basically
update the space in the table.
And then we said the way to improve it
is to reduce fill factor from 100 to 80.
What is better long term,
with an index on that column
or reduce the fill factor?
- [Baji] It's not because there
is no index on the column,
it's because how Postgres...
Postgres needs to update all
the indexes for those DMLs.
Irrespective if you're updating
non index column or not,
but those indexes should be updated.
Imagine if I don't have index,
I don't need index on that column,
but still I am making Postgres to update
all those indexes unnecessarily.
But those indexes should
be aware of these updates.
So how can we do that? So
that's where this feature helps.
Instead of updating
indexes, create pointers,
you can at least reduce
the time of updating.
So those pointers should be
available in the same block,
it can't be in the new block.
So that's why we need space in that block
to update those pointers.
- [Speaker] Thank you.
- [Baji] Another maybe
disadvantage is if you have
that free space in that block,
your inserts need more blocks.
So asking your operating
system to give you a block
to update the data is again overhead.
So if you have more updates
on that table, less inserts,
then you can go for that fill
factor to leave that space.
Otherwise, your inserts
need more and more blocks
because you're leaving
that space in each block.
So if you look at this
function definition, TDL,
this is a select on order items column.
This is a simple select,
but if you look at
order_items column table,
this is a partition table
with daily partition,
it's each day partition.
You can see 731 partition.
So now, we know that if
we have a WHERE clause
on partition key, it goes
to partition pruning.
But before that optimizer needs to
get a lock on each partition first
and then it prunes the exact
partition for the data,
but still it needs to
lock all the partitions.
Now Postgres by default allows...
In Postgres there is a
non-fastpath and fastpath locking.
Fastpath locking is reduces the overhead
of acquiring the locks.
So by default, only 16 of
fastpath locks can be acquired
for each query.
So now if you have a partition
table with 700 partitions,
so 700 different independent tables,
so now it has to acquire
locks, 700 locks on that table.
So obviously it goes to
non-fastpath locking,
which is some overhead.
So that's why you see
particularly lock manager,
lock manager events for this query.
So that lock manager event occurs
when your query has more
number of non-fastpath locking.
So just to check, if I begin
and execute this function,
select * from function
and let's check the number
of locks for that particular,
I'll just reconnect to the database.
Select count of logs from pg_locks.
So it acquired around 1300 locks.
But if I remove the fastpath locks,
there are still 800 non-fastpath locks.
This is because it acquired
lock on each partition.
But I have a new table
for this order items,
order_items_new,
which comes with monthly
partition, not daily partition.
This has the same amount of data
as this order_items partition table,
but it has less number of partitions.
If I update this function just to check,
update this function to
use the partition table,
which has less number
of partitions instead
and if you select this
function in a transaction,
if I go back here and check
the non-fastpath locks,
those are significantly reduced.
So all those difference of
locks over it has been reduced.
And also if you keep observing,
you don't see those lock manager events
or see very less amount of
lock manager events here.
So this will affect the query performance
because of that locking overhead.
We've fixed five queries.
And one last thing I want
to show is about indexes.
So if you have unused or
duplicate indexes unnecessarily,
no database needs to update
or insert data into those indexes,
which is again, heavy work.
This is a query to check unused indexes.
This is not a query build by me,
this, you can find it in wiki.
So if I execute this query
to find unused indexes in my database,
I'll get rid of this transaction.
And you can see lot of
unused indexes are there
and duplicate indexes as well.
Sometimes in development instances
we keep checking indexes usage
and we create more and more indexes
and sometimes we forget to
drop the duplicate indexes.
We create multiple indexes and we forget.
So that's where the
duplicate indexes comes up.
If you check the duplicate indexes,
there are 14 duplicate indexes.
Not only that, these
indexes are around five
to six gigabytes in size.
It's unnecessary stories as well.
Now I can drop those indexes
and see the performance.
I'm getting rid of the connections
because dropping indexes
will take some time with that connections.
But if I execute this drop index command,
it gives me a set of drop index
commands for this as well,
for duplicate indexes as well.
There are 14 duplicate indexes.
Now if I go back to this query
where I'm terminating all the connections
and now run the duplicate command,
you just need to execute, gexecute
so that all those drop
commands will get executed.
And same for duplicate indexes as well.
You just need to execute, gexecute.
So now all those indexes were dropped,
all unused and duplicate indexes.
We can keep observing,
our loads and data has
restarted all the queries.
So we can keep observing these queries
and you can see the improvement.
So we started with somewhere
around 14,000, 12,000 queries
and after fixing our five
queries, we are at 24,000 queries
so more than 100%
improvement with this tuning.
Thus, it takes some
time to send the report
but meanwhile, if you have any
questions, I'm happy to take.
- [Speaker] I just wanted to confirm,
when you did the HOT updates,
you made that change,
you didn't change the
code in any way, correct?
It was just 'cause you've-
- [Baji] No, no.
- [Speaker] Had some spare space.
- [Baji] I just changed
tables fill factor.
- [Speaker] Okay, thanks.
The second question,
are you aware of any development
underway for Postgres
or for Aurora Postgres to
consolidate query plans?
For example, if you have a query
and it's got a certain comment,
but the rest of the text is identical,
it produces a different hash.
Or if you have spaces or carriage returns,
same query, same number of parameters,
but spacing's a little different,
it's a different query hash.
Are you aware of any efforts
to consolidate those queries
that are actually the
same query functionally
into one hash or have
some kind of mapping?
- [Baji] Honestly, I'm
not, but if you have hints,
it'll remove the hints
to generate the SQL hash
for that particular query.
Or if you have explained
whatever before that select,
it removes those hints
to generate SQL hash.
But if you have spaces
or enters, then you know
it's a different SQL hash.
But I'm not aware of anything
that's being developed
to enhance that.
- [Vlad] Well, we can capture
this as a feature request
for the service team and see
if they can work on that.
(indistinct chattering)
So, I mean the entire extension
is available only for Aurora
it's our extension, so we
should be able to do it.
It's just a matter of
prioritizing the work
based on relative to customer needs.
So we can just, we can definitely
let the service team
know about this request.
You would, or you know,
now that we know about it,
we can put in this each
request for the service team.
All right?
All right. Thanks everyone. Thanks Baji.
That was wonderful.
- [Baji] Thank you.
Thanks for joining.
- [Vlad] Great job.